I think why I love sports
is, like--
I did a whole thing on it,
this show, once.
It's the last institution
I can trust.
-Mm-hmm.
-Like I don't trust anything.
I don't trust the media,
I don't trust the government.
STEPHEN SMITH:
I don't blame you.
-No-- Right.
-I don't blame you.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS, APPLAUDS)
But I-- But--
(APPLAUSE)
There are nepo babies
everywhere.
-Even modeling now.
-STEPHEN: Yeah.
You used to have to really be,
you know--
It's all the children of,
or a lot of it.
Okay.
Politics, show business...
There are no nepo babies
in sports.
Bronny James, everybody wants
to see him play with his father,
but he will not get on that team
unless he absolutely earns it.
I have total trust
that the 600 people
who play in baseball,
or whatever it is, 400, 500,
-are the best in the world.
-STEPHEN: Right.
-Am I right? Right.
-You're right about it
if you're talking about
the athletes.
There's certainly nepo babies
in the front office,
there's nepo babies
in the coaching staff.
-Right. Everywhere else.
-STEPHEN: Make no mistake
about that...
in the world of sports.
But not when it comes
to the athletes.
Here's the reason why.
You're performing
in a public platform.
You don't get to suck
and the audience
is going to ignore you.
You're not getting away
with that.
-Well, and they want to win.
-And they want--
Well, again, they want to win--
But for example,
one of the rare cases
where that happens,
Giannis Antetokounmpo
for the Milwaukee Bucks,
his little brother
is on the roster
and gets no playing time
whatsoever.
That's the closest thing
you can point to to a nepo--
But that's about it.
You've got to be able to play.
And like with Bronny James,
here's the interesting part
about that,
I think that kid can play,
I think he's got potential.
Is he there yet? No.
But I think he's got
the potential to be there.
But LeBron James
went front and center
from day one and said,
"I want to play in the NBA
with my son."
And because LeBron James
is still elite,
averaging nearly 25 a game
at the age of 39
in his 21st season
in professional basketball,
he's such a money maker
that the thought
of LeBron James coming
to any franchise,
even if it's just for a year,
you're thinking about
the financial windfall
from all of that.
And if LeBron comes there
and all we gotta do
is get Bronny James,
you never know who might
decide to do that.
But in the end,
if Bronny James
makes it to the NBA
and he ultimately survives
in the NBA,
it will be because
he can play.
Not because of his dad.
So you're absolutely right.
The nepo babies that
you're talking about,
that doesn't happen
in professional sports.
The public won't let you
get away with it.